non
[Musique]
alors je voudrais vous raconter une
histoire et je voudrais vous emmener
dans le désert dans le désert du nevada
aux états unis où on a construit un
temple un temple de 60 mètres de large
de 20 mètres de haut avec 120 bénévoles
qui sont venus pour partager leurs
histoires personnelles et voilà je vais
vous partager cela et je vais vous
emmener un peu partout parce que c'est
le résultat d'une approche
une approche qui m'a a changé au fil du
temps voilà mon bureau à londres où je
suis depuis 16 ans voilà notre machine
on a plein de machines
c'est ainsi une imprimante 3d géante et
contrairement au bureau d'architecturé
où il ya des des ordinateurs nous on a
plutôt des objets des objets qu'on
produit à l'échelle réelle on partage on
a un peu cassé les lignes habituelles
voilà des ingénieurs des des domaines
pluridisciplinaire on réfléchit à la
ville de demain une ville qui peut être
que ça semblait et peut-être se
désassembler comme dans la nature
voilà une vision d'un bâtiment qui
pourrait peut-être changer notre
conception permanente des bâtiments
alors pour faire cela il faut il faut
réfléchir il faut surtout avoir beaucoup
d'outils et beaucoup de curiosité donc
cette méthode encourage la curiosité on
a fait un robot qui là est exposée à la
tate modern à londres et qui est
fabriquée entièrement dans notre fab lab
donc on a un fab lab s'appelle le fap
pub dans lequel toute la communauté peut
venir et construire des choses et on
encourage cette créativité et on se dit
sous un petit peu dans la communauté
pour essayer d'aider avoir la vision de
demain
voilà burning man dans le désert je sais
pas si certains d'entre vous y sont
allés mais c'est un endroit où on peut
lâcher prise des conventions lâché prise
dès des règles et inventer réinventer
les bâtiments réinventer la notion de
ville puisque chaque année la ville se
recrée donc cette approche a grandi peu
à peu et je vous raconterai canton
comment est-ce qu'on a fini par
construire ce c'est impossible disent on
a défié l'impossible petit à petit donc
je peux vous raconter cette histoire
mais voilà le bâtiment
presque fini puisque au final ce
bâtiment n'a jamais été vraiment très
fini et il continue jusqu'à aujourd'hui
où je vous raconte cette histoire
voilà donc j'ai eu mon diplôme en 2008
pendant la crise de 2008 que vous avez
sûrement vécu comme moi sauf que moi
j'étais le moment où j'ai eu mon diplôme
et je devais rejoindre un travail pas
facile
pas facile mais mes parents m'ont éduqué
avec des valeurs voilà mais mes parents
des hippies des années 70 mon père il
est là il est déménagé de tunisie pour
venir à sarcelles dans la banlieue
parisienne et une bras compter que tous
les matins prenez son scooter pour aller
étudier l'informatique à jussieu c'est
là qu'il a rencontré ma mère une
attachée de presse pour un groupe de
rock star et ensemble ils ont partagé
une passion une passion de comment
réconcilier l'informatique et
l'environnement où l'humain et le
technologique et c'est un peu ces
valeurs qui ont continué dans mon
travail et c'est vrai que au final
larchitecture sait beaucoup de choses et
les catégorisations peut-être ne
s'applique pas toujours quand on
réfléchit à l' architecture des choses
donc voilà j'ai commencé comme j'ai pu
je faisais des vitrines des vitrines à
londres et voilà par exemple un exemple
d'architecturé paramétrique c'est à dire
que les paramètres définissent ce qui se
passe dans ce tissu donc à la place de
réfléchir à des concepts dans mon esprit
et je vais dessiner et je les donne
c'est plus on fait grandir ses projets
on les laisse émerger
on les laisse venir du du bottom ap on
dit en anglais c'est à dire pas le top
down
ça vient pas du haut ça vient du
matériau ça vient de notre compréhension
de de ce que le matériau peut faire la
compréhension de la machine et vous
voyez j'ai c'est que das lied et comme
ça et je pense que avec cette approche
puisque on est les meilleurs
son projet on apprend un peu à dessiner
avec ses contraintes
donc je pense que dans cette approche
pousse à dessiner dans plus dans une
sorte de vide mais dans une sorte de
compréhension de la réalité
donc voilà je vous montre des projets
qui sont faits après cette première
vitrine qui m'a un peu donner une
vitrine d'une certaine manière
voilà par exemple un projet fou virgin
galactic nous a demandé de faire un
hôtel
dans le désert pour les astronautes
avant qui qui partent et je me rappelais
de cette technique
quand j'ai appris l'informatique avec
mon père s'appelait logo c'est une
petite tortue qui avançaient comme ça et
puis on lui disait d'avancer de deux
tournées l'avancé de tourner et on l'a
laissé tourner et c est ça crée des
formes presque naturelle des formes qui
que je pouvais pas prévoir en fait donc
les formes s'auto générer et donc ça
change vraiment la conception du
créateur puisque le créateur d'habitude
là il a des visions qui vient du ciel et
et c'est un génie et c'est alors que
l'as pas du tout c'est une petite tortue
qui se baladent et alors je leur ai
montré ça et c'est devenu un projet qui
est vraiment à la base de ce qu'on a
fait à burning man une approche on lâche
prise et c'est à peu près à cette époque
là que j'ai commencé à aussi à me
familiariser aux technologies de
l'impression 3d
l'idée que le robot peut être connectée
à cette petite tortue le fait qu'on
pouvait envoyer des lignes et les
fabriquer directement et les envoyés des
machines donc cette approche a beaucoup
permis de comprendre comment est ce
qu'on pourrait par exemple avoir une
approche un peu plus environnemental si
elle est un peu plus globale
alors je vais vous expliquer par exemple
au travers de de ces deux concepts le
concept de berceau au berceau
le président claude en anglais qui sera
proche de l'idée du du cycle de vie des
matériaux c'est à dire que on utilise un
matériau qui vient du sol et qui repart
vers le sol et ce matériau qu'on a
utilisé ça s'appelle le bioplastique cdu
du sucre fermenté et voilà on l'a
utilisé dans un projet par exemple qu'on
a fait ici pour cause la marque de
vêtements et on a été dans un palais
dont je vais vous emmener en désert mais
ça commence ici dans ce palais voilà
donc on a réfléchi à une sorte de
concept de modularité qui a permis
d'entraîner tous les fab lab qui étaient
autour du site et du coup on en voyait
notre code et le code était fabriqué sur
place
donc c'était un défi phénoménal puisque
c'est un des projets les plus grands
jamais imprimé en 3d mais j'étais bien
sûr habitué je trans au défi parce que
voilà
une ville qui est par elle même un défi
constant puisque chaque année elle suit
ses dix règles règles de 2 voilà dans
une banque lui ions radical d'économie
du don il n'y a pas vraiment de
commercialisation dire que l'on n'est
pas pignon doit on doit lever les fonds
de nos projets l'idée d'autonomie
radical et d'expression personnelle
radical terre qui a pas de spectateurs
ou d'artistes on est tous des artistes
on peut tous faire quelque chose on peut
tous réinventer cette ville et on ne lit
on ne livre no choice ans ne laisse
aucune trace nulle part
et donc c'est une fille vraiment un
projet qui au début je me rendais pas
compte un moment ça a l'air de faire
tellement de sens mais ça
au début j'ai glissé mais c'est vraiment
proche des valeurs que qui était propre
à l' architecture que je faisais aux
valeurs de mes parents et voilà donc
notre un nouveau premier projet et
engine aujourd'hui mme les rêves
tangentielle qui est un projet pour eux
qui inviter les gens à écrire sur sept
ans jantes des tangentes qui crée une
sorte de mouvement et qui est invité à
voile à la contemplation et surtout à
une sorte de vandalisme positif parce
que les gens étaient encouragés à écrire
à monthey a vraiment et puis au final
c'était pas que les gens qui utilisaient
le bâtiment s'était aussi les gens qui
le construisent et donc on a invité
plein de gens j'ai invité mes amis j'ai
invité et encore une fois je vous
inviterai tous essayé mais mais voilà
donc le bâtiment ne se commande pas
quand il est ouvert
il se commence dès la construction des
l'implication de la communauté et
burning man m'a fait un énorme honneur
gens croient toujours pas mes yeux
mais ils m'ont dit est ce que tu
voudrais construire le temple alors le
temple c'est un espace qui est très
important c'est le petit cercle et tout
à la fin d' à l'opposé du sorte de l'arc
de cercle
et c'est un espace spirituel alors
l'idée dans l'espace virtuel est
peut-être trop blanc parce qu'on associe
souvent à la religion mais ce qui
m'avait beaucoup touché moi c'est que
c'était pas un un espace religieux y
avait pas forcément
le dogme d'une religion associés et
pourtant j'y suis allée avec ma femme et
on a pleuré on a complètement pleuré
c'était la première fois que je
ressentais ça dans un bâtiment et dont
j'ai voulu exprimer ses émotions j'ai
voulu exprimer l'idée qu'on puisse avoir
un espace dans lequel c'est ok de ne pas
de troc est d'une certaine manière j'ai
eu plusieurs dépressions j'en ai assez
souffert et je n'ai jamais vraiment
ressenti le fait que je pouvais le
partager et c'est vrai que ce projet m'a
aidé à en parler m'a aidé à le
communiquer à l'équipe a à leur dire et
pas quelle équipe à communauté et et
quand on partage ses émotions quand on
partage sa sa bulle la mairie une vérité
les hommes partagent en retour et voilà
donc voyez par exemple les petits coeurs
qui sont autour du temple c'est un homme
qui voilà qui faisait des papes ont de
coeur tout autour et je m'en suis rendu
compte que quand j'ai vu cette photo
mais c'était vraiment quelque chose
d'exceptionnel et ce n'est pas la seule
chose les gens encore une fois écrivait
partout c'était à eux c'est à dire que
le temple était à eux il peut faire ce
qu'il voulait ils pouvaient débarquer
danser et pouvait faire ce qu'ils
voulaient y avait aucune contrainte dans
cet espace et au milieu il y avait ses
larmes que je pensais pouvait
représenter la fragilité de chacun est
ce qui m'a permis peut-être de
communiquer cet esprit des larmes qu'on
a imprimé sur place des technologies
d'une certaine manière nous a permis de
réaliser ce rêve mais d'une certaine
manière au fond c'était les gens
c'étaient les gens qui nous permettait
d'assemblée ces éléments qui au final
était assez complexe mais cette
complexité
avais tu sens qu'avec eux et donc y
avait une communication constante et il
me disait qu est ce qui n'allait pas
qu'est ce qui marchait qu'est ce qui
marchait pas et je vous donne de trois
exemples voici par exemple le module
qu'on ferme tous ensemble ça donne un
peu une idée de l'échelle
on en avait à peu près 400 à appuyer
comme ça et voilà donc il y avait une
sorte de satisfaction avec le temps donc
on commence avec le le morceau de bois
conforme en triangle conforme en espèces
d'origami conflit et est donc à vie dans
la durée cette espèce de courbes de
compréhension c'était un projet
phénoménal enfin en termes de taille
vous pouvez voir que un de ces éléments
que je vous montrais dans la vidéo c'est
un des éléments de la grille juste pour
vous donner une idée de l'échelle et
bien sûr des tempêtes de sable et des
moments vraiment magique
voilà j'ai c'était vraiment difficile
j'ai eu des crises de panique j'ai je
savais pas si j'avais les épaules de le
faire et j'étais bien sûr n'avait pas
d'argent pour le faire on a fait des
fêtes on a fait des délais levée de
fonds mais à un moment il manquait à peu
près 300 mille dollars et j'ai été
complètement voilà j'avais rendez vous
avec la banque pour faire un prêt
puisque je savais pas comment lever le
reste et je me suis dit moi je vais
envoyer des emails je vais communiquer
ce que voilà mon problème mais je l'aï
envoyé comme ça j'ai tenté tout toute la
communauté mark iv facebook.com et tout
ça les gens que je pensais qu'ils
allaient écouter le message est il ya
sergei breen le fondateur de google qui
met en rang d'oignons une heure et qui
m'a dit ok en l'honneur du fondateur de
burning man qui malheureusement était
décédé juste avant je vais couvrir le
leur est un message improbable
improbable de recevoir un e-mail pareil
non seulement ça mais il est venu me
voir il arrive pendant qu'on
construisait tous donc il faut savoir
que le site et est énorme et il arrive
comme ça
et dans l'équipe je veux le dire on a
fait des to de tous les domaines on
revient on avait même un sdf quelqu'un
qui avec qui on avait au même qu'on
avait aidé à la halle faire venir parce
qu'ils pouvaient pas se permettre le
ticket tout ça et je vois donc cette
omnes en mai en anglais qui arrive avec
un magicien
voilà un mec adian magicien et puis on
se dira ce qu'est ce qu'il fait là
un casque que c'est que ces conneries il
court vers moi et il fait ce guet et
quand c'est rendu compte qu'il y avait
là qu'est ce qui te dis moi ton cerveau
et et il dit ouais ben vas-y mais elle
est où la perceuse vas-y annula est bon
c'est vrai c'était c'est un peu cette
magique que je voulais communiquer c'est
à dire que quand on a un projet commun
qu'importe d'où on vient qu'importe de
ce qu'on peu ce qu'on fait qu importe
son statut
on était tous pareils on était tous
pareils on sait tous la vaisselle on
faisait tous voilà les toilettes dans le
même endroit pourri où il fallait voilà
et il ya un côté démocratique dans la
construction un côté universel d'une
certaine manière qui nous a poussé à
créer quelque chose qui au final était
lui aussi à vocation universelle donc
voilà ça va de l'infiniment grand aux
tâches de 2,10 watching the vessel donc
on avait ce quotidien avec des équipes
des équipes de cuisine des équipes de 2
to en fait et c'était un petit monde
pendant 18 jours on était dans notre
petit monde et on a été tellement
tellement satisfait quand on l'a donné à
la communauté et c'est ce qu'on a
vraiment ressenti c'était un cadeau
qu'on faisait aux autres et voilà et je
me tiens en enfants mais on la chimie et
puis on commence à entendre comme ça des
perceuses des trucs et germain c'est pas
fini et en fait c'était les autres les
autres qui voient là qu'ils étaient des
trucs qui faisait des hôtels et qui
communiquer ces messages qui était
vraiment au final tellement émouvant que
c'était dur de ne pas se ressentir quand
même en faisant partie comme un élément
un de ses éléments de cette la tis
énorme en fait et je me suis marié
voila voila ma mère avec son et garonne
ckb voilages années 70 celle ci est
retrouvée
et voilà donc c'était une manière aussi
de montrer que ce n'était pas que un
projet qui pour le pour faire le deuil
c'était aussi un projet pour le futur
pour un espace qui peut permettre à des
moments joyeux à des rituels
nous voilà dans en dansant sur all you
need is love des beatles et voici mon
père que vous pouvez voir ici tout à
fait dans son élément
ah bon après on s'est complètement
écroulé j'ai peut-être dormi sur tout du
long
mais c'était aussi ça le fait de donner
on a on a on avait je pense mériter de
de passer du temps à ne plus y réfléchir
et à laisser s'apaiser ce ce projet
d'une certaine manière le laisser se
sent prêt n'y ait de la communauté de
leurs désirs et d'une manière c'était
son rôle y connecter ce ce désert à ses
plats au ciel au aux paysages à côté et
voilà on l'a brûlée alors on l'a brûlée
parce que ça fait partie de ce rituel de
lâcher prise et on l'a brûlée parce que
c'était construit pour être brûlés je
vous encourage pas à brûler quoi que ce
soit mais c'est vrai qu'en tant qu
architecte c'est l'exercice ultime pour
oublier son ego c'est l'exercice ultime
pour re questionner ses créations pour
se réinventer de manière permanente et
on l'a nettoyé
on a tout mis dans des petits tas on a
tous recyclés pour l'année d'après pour
le temple d'après pour que l'expérience
continue pour les gens d'après et je
vais vous montrer un projet pour finir
qui est ce qu'on va faire cet été on va
essayer de changer un peu ce rituel est
de créer un bâtiment qu'on va construire
depuis qu'on va déconstruire dans
l'esprit burning man c'est un
amphithéâtre fed amphithéâtre où tout le
monde peut faire sa performance
et on va essayer de le reconstruire ici
ici en europe où presque à londres voilà
le somerset house ouais malheureusement
[Rires]
comme ça plus de gens puissent pourront
ressentir ce qu'on peut peut-être sentir
là bas dans les sprints lutte inclusion
radical voilà donc je vous invite à me
rejoindre
si c'est vraiment ça vous intéresse on
va faire un appel
voilà un appel aux gens pour qu'ils nous
rejoignent et voilà je vous invite à
réfléchir à cette à cette idée peut-être
que la ville de demain peut-être ne
laissera aucune trace physique peut-être
qu'elle se défaire à elle se refera
autre part peut-être qu'elle sera un
tout petit peu plus sensible à l'écouté
des gens et peut-être au final vous vous
vous rejoignent réa à moi pour essayer
de faire partie de la construction de la
ville de demain
voilà merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]